Donald Trump has instructed his
administration to halt funding of the
World Health Organization Trump says the
w-h-o failed in its early response to
the coronavirus the u.s. president who
has himself come under fire for his
handling of the pandemic said the w-h-o
should have done a better job of
investigating initial reports in China
UN Secretary Antonio Guterres responded
by saying that now was not the time to
and support for the w-h-o he said it's
work was absolutely critical to the
global effort to combat kovat 19 Trump
says the roughly 400 million dollars in
annual donations will now be paused and
decision drew a sharp rebuke from the
German Foreign Minister hai Kumar said
in a tweet blaming does not help the
virus knows no borders we should work
together closely against Kove 819 one of
the best investments is to strengthen
the UN especially the underfunded w-h-o
for example in the development and
distribution of tests and vaccines Bill
Gates too called the move dangerous well
former UK Prime Minister Gordon Brown
has been calling for a stronger global
response to the pandemic and he joins us
now from five in Scotland mr. Brown
thanks for being with us what do you
make of Donald Trump's decision to stop
funding the World Health Organization
well you know and March the 26 Donald
Trump signed a communique that he was
present at the meeting of the g20 when
they said they would strengthen the wh
O's mandate they would increase the
funding for disaster response they would
give more money so it could develop a
new virus and they would help that deal
with the problems facing the developing
countries this is not only an illogical
step by the president it's an act of
self harm because to protect ourselves
locally in Germany or in America we have
to act globally and if this disease has
a second and third round in Africa or in
the developing world and then comes back
to the West and then will be to blame
for not helping those African countries
that the W Choice intent on supporting
protect themselves when they have
underdeveloped health systems and purse
or social safety nets and canted or
the social distancing and other measures
that we are adopting in the West I want
to talk about those African governments
there was African countries in this
pandemic in just a moment but first
we've seen national governments leading
the response to this pandemic so far
have transnational organizations like
the w-h-o or the UN failed I think each
individual organizations trying its best
but you know when I had to deal with
others with the global financial crisis
in 2009 we were only able to say we will
do whatever it can which is what you've
got to be able to say when we brought
everyone together we brought the
international organizations that I met
from the World Bank and the UN and the
WTO but we'd also brought national
leaders together in one forum the g20
and what's missing at the moment is this
concerted action together by world
leaders and even if America is reluctant
to start with and even if China is
operating bilaterally I think the
European Union Japan the rest of Asia
Africa pushing us along I think we could
get this global coordination and it's
necessary one to finance the search for
a cure and for a vaccine and for
diagnostics and therapeutics secondly to
build capacity because we're out bidding
each other at the moment for a limited
capacity we've got to build capacity in
test kits and build it in ventilators
and everything else and thirdly of
course to prevent the second and third
round of disease which has to be done by
acting collectively and you recently
helped pen an open letter to the g20 it
was signed by more than 200 former world
leaders and called for a coordinated
global response to the corona virus who
do you think should lead that response I
think we need two things first of all a
pledging conference to deal with the
financing of global health and I do
believe that the European Union has a
major role to play in leading this
bringing in Japan Canada Korea and then
bringing in China and America and I
think secondly we need a g20 task force
we need this coordination on a
week-to-week day-to-day level if we're
going to get the world economy back to
growth then there will be a moment when
we need to expand demand in the economy
at the moment we're in employment
protection soon we will have to restore
demand
and that will required coordinated
fiscal monetary and central bank
policies and it will also require the
international institutions the IMF and
the World Bank to be given by the
politicians the power and the money that
will enable them to support developing
country economies g20 finance ministers
are about to release their global action
plan as a former finance minister
yourself chancellor of the exchequer in
the UK do you think that plan should
include debt relief for africa
indefinitely I've got an article in The
Washington Post today with the Larry
Summers which is saying 76 of the
low-income countries in the world should
get immediate debt relief for this year
and for next year not just for a few
months but they are spending more on
debt interest payments at the moment
than they are on their health systems it
is against our self-interest that need
not spending on health we have got to
help them do that one of the quickest
ways is debt relief we will have to
increase the Special Drawing rights of
the IMF we will have to give the World
Bank and the IMF power to lend and to
grant more money all these things are
going to be necessary and it ought to be
synchronized and brought together in one
plan and I hope on Friday when the IMF
and World Bank meet that they will agree
that a plan that includes debt relief is
urgently required and has to be pushed
forward mr. parelle thank you so much
for talking with us that was former UK
Prime Minister Gordon Brown thank you